the start of the ashes test at Lords The
Prestige event at the home of cricket
and a prime target for protesters
the end of the first over balled by
England their chosen moment for
disruption
evading security to reach the Outfield
and spreading orange powder paint the
Hallmark of just stop oil
England's Johnny bairstow alerts the
danger carrying the defiant demonstrator
back to the boundary rope taking matters
into his own hands
while across the pitch there was another
activist
who was blocked by England Captain Ben
Stokes in Australia batter David Warner
from reaching the square but they were
still able to disperse the powder before
being wrestled to the ground
the cleanup operation began swiftly
foreign
of Spectators was clear it's gotten
ridiculous they've done this so many
times and I understand their point I
agree with some of their points but how
they're going about it is terribly wrong
I think Johnny bairstow showed his
Yorkshire Roots by picking them up and
carrying them off quite well so I think
it they they handled it quite well the
players actually I don't believe that
interrupting a sports match is is the
way to go about it but you know what is
the best way I don't know play was only
disrupted for a few minutes but the
owners of Lords said the actors showed
complete disregard for The Spectators
it's unlikely to be the last we've seen
of sporting events being used as a
platform for protest we've just stopped
oil vowing to continue until the
government stops issuing new oil and gas
licenses powder protests also halted the
world snooker championships in April and
the rugby Premiership Final in May
police warn this week a potentially
deadly consequences of targeting the
British Grand Prix again after this
track Invasion last year
but just stop oil insists the dangerous
fossil fuels posed to the planet
outweigh any dangerous and protesting
and one of those Lord's protesters 69
year old Judith told Justin Boyle they
have to take action for my seven
beautiful grandchildren I can't bear to
imagine the suffering that they will
have to endure
three arrests were made at Lords and
Security will hope they aren't caught
out again as the Ash's test continues
Rob Harris Sky News Lords